travel is once again picking up and this
summer people are ready to hit the road
and we are getting some tips and tricks
from travel expert janine tornatore
janine welcome to the show we are
seeing people traveling like crazy
they're ready to get out of town
and as we head out of the fourth of july
weekend and beyond what are
some of your top picks for summer travel
well look there you're right this is an
unprecedented summer in terms of how
many people are out there traveling
and as we head into the second half of
the summer there's so much opportunity
you know we do start to see demand drop
somewhat when we get into august so if
you're looking later in the summer when
the kids head back to school that's a
really great time but even
you know early to mid july um that's top
busy season so
let's start with a staycation for folks
who just want to stay local look
it's places like the cosmopolitan i
think that really do it right for those
local staycations they have the
residential style suite so you really
kind of get that
um getaway feeling with those private
terraces so
looking for those types of properties if
you're doing a staycation something
where it's a little bit beyond just the
standard hotel room
but look if you want to get away for a
beach vacation san diego i think
is one of the best picks for a drive
getaway a five-hour drive from las vegas
um you know and here's why i like san
diego this summer san diego is
actually a big convention town so there
is a lot of hotel
inventory which means it's keeping
prices reasonable and there's still a
lot of availability even in places like
i love the westin and the gaslamp
quarter my family loves this one because
they have corn hole they have
table tennis on their sun deck so lots
of fun games to play a rooftop pool so
you kind of have that respite from any
crowds
but certainly you know san diego would
be my pick for a drive getaway
now if you're looking to fly somewhere
nashville nashville has been a hot
destination for a while but i love it in
the summer because i think you get the
best of both worlds you get that
fun downtown nashville vibe with all the
music
you have the ryman you have um so many
great things to do in the city
but it's also a great base point for
launching off into the smoky mountains
so you can get that outdoor escape and
hit some of those wonderful destinations
the renaissance would be my pick for a
hotel you're right downtown in the heart
of the city you have a great
bar restaurant scene right there within
your hotel
and lots of availability for this summer
as well and you're saying if you really
want to do a bucket list place
canada is the place to be huh well look
canada is really not completely open yet
but where everybody i think you know
that really likes to head north to get
kind of that cooler weather is looking
forward to that so places like montreal
and toronto i think keep those on your
list
and keep an eye out for when those do
reopen we're also
seeing that a lot of people are really
looking forward to
getting back to places like europe um
and people are already heading back
there this summer in fact marriott data
shows that
places like uh london paris rome munich
and madrid are really
kind of the hot places people are
looking to right now so
the good news for those international
travelers is that it is doable at this
point
we love that you have so much great
information janine thank you so much
happy travels
to you and jc over to you